From the meaning behind Ken's flashy fur coat
to the purpose of a pooping dog, let's explore
all the subtle jokes and references tucked
away in the "Barbie" movie.
One of the cool elements that director Greta
Gerwig brings to the film is calling attention
to the specific kinds of Barbies each character
represents.
Margot Robbie's "Stereotypical Barbie" look
doesn't outshine other Barbies, like Issa
Rae's "President Barbie" or Kate McKinnon's
hilarious "Weird Barbie."
"Hi, I'm weird Barbie.
I am in the splits, I have a funky haircut
and I smell like basement."
However, what really attracts the audience's
interest are the discontinued Barbie dolls,
which Gerwig includes to pay homage to both
the triumphs and mistakes of Mattel's ideas.
For example, Michael Cera plays Ken's best
buddy Allan, who was discontinued after Mattel
realized that kids were not even that interested
in playing with Ken, let alone his sidekick.
"There are no multiples of Allan.
He's just Allan."
"Yeah, I'm confused about that."
Additionally, Emerald Fennell plays the often-forgotten
Midge, who is a discontinued pregnant doll.
You can see other infamous discontinued dolls
like "Video Girl Barbie," who functioned as
a working video camera, and "Earring Magic
Ken" who has an earring and… a big round necklace.
One scene that was featured in the first trailer
and opens the film is the little girls' revolt
against baby dolls.
With Helen Mirren narrating, the scene is
cinematically gripping.
In it, young girls solemnly play with their
baby dolls and act as mothers, while Mirren
tells the audience how little girls were always
force-fed the baby doll.
That is, until Barbie came on the scene, showing
little girls that the role of mother was not
the only aspiration they could have.
As a result of seeing Robbie's powerful stance,
the little girls smash their baby dolls and
revolt against this motherly ideology to opt
for a Barbie.
The scene might seem slightly off-putting
to those who haven't seen the original source
material, but the "Barbie" opening is entirely
based on the opening from "2001: A Space Odyssey."
However, instead of an alien monolith appearing
before a crowd of cavemen, Robbie's beautiful
1950s swimsuit-clad presence dominates the
scene.
The young women are inspired by Robbie's Barbies,
and instead of breaking skulls like the cavemen
do, the little girls smash their baby dolls
in the same intense, animalistic manner.
A baby doll is thrown into the air before
transitioning into the "Barbie" logo, a clear
homage to Stanley Kubrick's famous match shot
in "2001: A Space Odyssey" that turns a flying
bone into a satellite.
The entire scene is absurd in these circumstances,
but manages to cover a lot of exposition to
contextualize Barbie for the audience.
One of the key elements to perfecting the
"Barbie" movie comes from recreating the doll's
iconic looks.
Costume designer Jacqueline Durran wanted
to fully capture the history of the doll by
recreating some of the most memorable and
niche costumes for casual fans and superfans
alike to enjoy.
The designer started with the very first look
you see Robbie's Barbie wearing: The 1959 Barbie swimsuit.
This look is featured in the "2001: A Space
Odyssey" parody opening scene, with Robbie
sporting a black and white one-piece swimsuit,
red lipstick, and sharp sunglasses.
The recreation of this look is almost identical
to the earliest model of the Barbie doll.
It makes sense to start the film off with
Barbie's origin, and Durran absolutely nails it.
If you are anywhere on the internet, then
you've probably seen the video of Ryan Gosling
at 12 years old dancing in an episode of "Star
Search."
He stands, front and center, with a group
of dancers, and absolutely tears it up for
the whole audience to see.
The MC Hammer pants, the facial expressions,
and everything else about the video is incredible
and totally on brand.
However, nothing could prepare you for Gosling's
song and dance movies in the "Barbie" movie.
Gerwig truly leaned into the hype surrounding
Gosling's resurfaced video and created a musical masterpiece.
Ken sings about his meaningless existence,
giving the audience more insight into Barbie's
male accessory.
This musical number is a great callback to
Gosling's younger days and gives the movie
more of a quirky tone, if that's even possible.
"No one rests until this doll is back in a
box."
Barbie has many sidekicks, including siblings,
friends, and, of course, Ken.
However, Barbie also has several pets, including
a golden retriever named Tanner.
One of the quick little moments in the "Barbie"
movie that you might miss is the inclusion
of Barbie's dog, Tanner.
When Barbie goes to Weird Barbie's house,
she finds the dog walking through the house
and leaving poop pellets along the way.
The dog is only present for a few seconds,
but real Barbie fans recognize it right away.
One Barbie toy that was discontinued was Tanner,
an accompaniment for Potty Training Barbie.
When Barbie would walk the dog, it would drop
poop pellets, and Barbie would have the tools
to pick them up.
The problem, though, was that the pellets
were so small that they constituted a choking
hazard for small children.
Additionally, the toy was recalled because
the small magnet in the scooper fell off way
too easily, providing yet another safety issue
for kids.
This toy is one that lives in infamy, but
is certainly a hilarious addition to the "Barbie" movie.
There are many Barbie universe references
throughout the film, and pretty much every
single one of them is called out by Helen
Mirren's narration.
However, because of all of them, it seems
especially jarring when the reference is unrelated
to Barbie.
Fans will notice the discussion surrounding
"Pride and Prejudice" and the feminine right
to watch it whenever they want.
There's also the brief discussion about loving
Zack Snyder's "Justice League" cut and the
masculine urge to shove that in everyone's
face.
However, there are some quirkier and more
subtle references too, like Weird Barbie offering
Barbie the truth or a way to ignore everything
with a high heel and a Birkenstock.
This is a nod to the red pill and blue pill
decision from "The Matrix."
Or, in the montage sequences, there are brief
clips from "The Godfather," "Grease" and other
popular pieces of media.
So it's great to watch Gerwig give both subtle
and blatant nods to popular culture.
Can we get some applause for Ken's outfit
choices throughout the film?
Most of the focus in costume conversations
surrounding the film comes from Barbie's looks,
and rightfully so.
However, the choices for Ken's outfits are
just as incredible.
"Did you bring your rollerblades?"
"I literally go nowhere without them."
In keeping with the theme of making numerous
pop culture references throughout the film,
there are many references to Sylvester Stallone,
and to "Rocky" as a whole.
They are mostly subtle but the biggest reference
comes from Ken's outfit choice when he takes
over Barbieland with the patriarchy in tow.
His giant white fur coat and no shirt make
for a bougie look — and a reference.
Sylvester Stallone wore that white fur coat
in the '70s and '80s, even earning himself
a GQ article about it.
Gosling learns about the patriarchy, horses,
and Stallone in the real world and takes all
of that, including Stallone's fashion choices,
back to Barbieland with him.
Though the coat in the film is fake fur, costume
designer Jacqueline Durran said that they
lined it with horse print as a homage to Ken's
obsession with horses.
For those who are fans of Stallone, and appreciate
Ken's love of horses, the coat is a nice little easter egg.
There is one particularly beautiful scene
in the movie that features Barbie telling
an older woman at the bus stop that she is
beautiful.
The woman, in response, says she "knows it,"
giving Barbie a nice smile.
The scene perfectly encapsulates what the
Barbie movie is all about, and it is one of
the most heartfelt moments in the film.
However, fans began speculating who the woman
is, and many were led to believe it was Barbara
Handler, daughter of Barbie inventor Ruth
Handler.
Pump the brakes, though, because that woman
actually is not Barbara Handler.
Instead, the woman in question is actually
Oscar-winning costume designer Ann Roth.
The scene is still particularly meaningful,
but does not have the connection to the Handler
family that many fans speculated.
However, there is a big mention of Barbara
Handler and the way she inspired Ruth to create
the Barbie doll, so she is not totally absent
from the film.
Though Barbara Handler was not actually featured
in "Barbie," Gerwig found a way to put her
mother Ruth Handler in the film.
Gerwig's cool way of paying homage to Barbie's
inventor is by having Rhea Pearlman play Ruth
in the film.
This is not just a glorified cameo either
— Handler and Barbie have a nice conversation
at the end of the film about humanity and
their relationship with one another.
However, the inclusion of Handler featured
a couple of quick jokes regarding Handler's
tax evasion, which fans might not understand.
In the 1970s, Handler was indicted after charges
of fraud and false reporting to the Securities
and Exchange Commission were brought to light.
She pleaded no contest and was fined $57,000.
In addition, she had to serve 2,500 hours
of community service.
Because there were no serious consequences,
it is something people feel comfortable joking
about, which is why Gerwig used it as a quick
quip in the film.
"Get that Barbie!"
Greta Gerwig is able to explore many themes
in the film, particularly about feminism,
coping with existence, and trying to find
your individuality in a world that demands
you to be perfect.
However, one more subtle theme that Gerwig
tackles throughout the movie comes from her
exploration of the way Barbie and Ken are
attached to one another, and who Ken is without Barbie.
"I'm coming with you."
"Okay."
A lot of the film revolves around Barbie's
crisis with who she is and what she was made for.
Meanwhile, Ken's crisis in the film is learning
about how he can be his own person and exist
as something other than an extension of Barbie.
It functions as an interesting take on the
creation myth in Genesis, and how their relationship
is like Adam and Eve, but flipped.
Barbie was invented as a way of empowering
women.
As a result, Ken was created after Barbie
to essentially function as a human accessory
to her — just as Eve was created after Adam.
Furthermore, Gerwig also found a way to play
on the concept of Eve being created from Adam's rib.
The director emphasizes this in reverse with
Barbie and Ken, showcasing how Ken was created
from Barbie's fame.
Though most of the "Barbie" movie focus comes
from Robbie and Gosling's performances, it's
important to acknowledge how incredible the
entire cast is, particularly America Ferrera.
She perfectly encapsulates what it is like
to be a woman, and the intense pressure women
are under to successfully make it through
even one day.
Her acting is lovely and her obsession with
Barbie is relatable — but we're not here
to talk about that.
We're here to talk about the quick little
line that references one of Ferrera's older,
iconic films: "Gotta Kick It Up."
Ferrera's character, Gloria, has to help Barbie
get Barbieland back from the Kens.
Meanwhile, her husband is learning Spanish
to better connect with his wife and daughter,
and says "Si Se Puede" to Barbie at the end
of the film.
Though the comment is one of encouragement,
essentially meaning "you can do it," it is
more of a nod to "Gotta Kick It Up" which
is alternately titled "Si Se Puede."
The reference could also extend to Ferrera
and Eva Longoria's digital lifestyle community
for Latin people called "She Se Puede."